new york's governor cat next governor
rather kathy hokel she's got two weeks
before she starts she's wasting no time
setting herself apart from governor
andrew cuomo he's resigning later this
month as we've been telling you this
week over multiple allegations of sexual
harassment though he denies any
wrongdoing in those cases hokel a former
congresswoman from buffalo has been new
york's lieutenant governor since 2015.
our national correspondent jerika duncan
has more now from albany where hokal
spoke to reporters for the first time
since cuomo's announcement jerica good
morning i will fight like hell for you
every single day
like i've always done and always will
democrat kathy hokel will make history
when she takes over as governor later
this month following governor andrew
cuomo's announcement that he will step
down
the best way i can help now
is if i step aside and let government
get back to governing
hokal was not mentioned in the state
attorney general's report that detailed
allegations of sexual harassment against
cuomo and she stressed she has not been
part of his inner circle i think it's
very clear that
the governor and i have not been close
physically or otherwise cuomo's top aide
melissa derosa who resigned sunday night
was mentioned in the report as working
to discredit at least one of cuomo's
accusers but she's now staying in her
job until cuomo departs
one has named who is named as anything
doing anything on ethical report will
remain in my administration houkel also
promised an overhaul in the office
culture i wanted to be a place people
feel welcome that all they have to worry
about is doing their job and fighting
for the people of new york along my side
and never have to worry about harassment
though cuomo will no longer be governor
state lawmakers will meet in albany
monday to discuss the future of their
impeachment investigation we asked
hulkel if she thinks lawmakers should
move forward it's not the responsibility
of a lieutenant governor at this time or
even a future governor to comment on
what the assembly is doing or the
judiciary committee but i have full
confidence
as just as i had confidence in the
attorney general in her report that
they'll come to the right conclusions
hokel said she never had plans to run
for governor before but now that she's
in this situation she says she
definitely plans to run for a full term
dana jerica thank you you've been doing
a great job on this story i know today
is your birthday happy birthday i hope
you get a little bit of break from some
of them i did not hear that happy yeah
it is her birthday i wanted to point it
out drinking thank you thank you enjoy
the day